there are few attacks on the freedom of
an independent press that are more
chilling than threatening reporters with
prison time and we just learned that
Donald Trump has done exactly that this
is truly a disturbing act that it would
be great to see it cross party lines it
should scare every single one of us and
that includes Republicans and Democrats
and it would be great to see both
Republicans and Democrats that are our
elected officials call this out but in
the world in which we exist today of
haphazard and knee-jerk defenses of
anything that Donald Trump says or does
I don't think we're going to see it okay
you might remember that Donald Trump
once had this letter that Kim jong-un
sent him I think he might have called it
a beautiful letter or something like
that Donald Trump had reporters in the
room at that time and he may have asked
to go off the record in terms of the
contents or maybe not and he held up the
letter and from what we have learned so
far a reporter from Time magazine held
up his camera to take a picture and
Donald Trump said and it's sort of
confusing and muddled and erratic like a
lot of what Donald Trump says but what
Trump said according to the transcript
is excuse me under Section two well you
can go to prison instead because if you
use if you use the photograph you took
of the letter that I gave you and time
tries to continue talking about the
topic of the interview do you believe
that people should be and Trump
interrupts interrupts confidentially I
didn't give it to you to take
photographs of it so don't play that
game with me let me just tell you
something you take a look time says I'm
sorry mr. president
were you threatening me with prison time
and Trump says well I told you the
following I told you you can look at
this off the record
that doesn't mean you take out your
camera and start taking pictures of it
okay
so I hope you don't have a picture of it
I know you were very quick to pull it
out even you were surprised to see that
you can't do that stuff so go have fun
with your story because I'm sure it will
be the 28th horrible story I have in
Time magazine because I never I mean huh
it's incredible
with all I've done and the success I've
had the way that Time magazine writes is
absolutely incredible
fascinatingly this riled him up so much
that he then went into a
huge rant about no collusion no
obstruction as a result of a
photographer taking a picture it is just
so incredible to read a transcript of
Donald Trump scolding a reporter for
taking a picture of something that Trump
gave confidentially which he doesn't
even understand the meaning of while he
has given up secrets from allies to
Russians in the Oval Office I mean it's
a jarring juxtaposition of what Trump
says and what Trump does and it's really
important to understand here when Trump
says he gave something confidentially
confidential as a classification of
documents you can't just yell out this
is confidential or you know this pen is
top secret
and make it so and it's also really
important to understand that it's Trump
who shouldn't be showing things to
people who don't have the correct
clearances and more importantly Trump
and his aides remember have bragged
endlessly
about how Trump can declassify anything
he wants by showing it to whoever he
wants if Trump shows someone the picture
then he has decided that it's okay for
them to see it it's also really funny
that Trump mentioned section two and
then he seemed to realize he didn't know
what he was talking about let's put the
transcript back up on the screen for a
moment Trump started to say excuse me
under Section two and then he kind of
went away from that and said well you
can go to prison instead I guess he
means article two of the Constitution or
maybe section 2 of article two during
the same confused interview he seemed to
be using the term section two an article
to kind of interchangeably like maybe
they're the same thing and he doesn't
know what he's talking about
article two has two sections of the
Constitution section one establishes
basically how the President and
vice-president are to be elected and
served four-year terms section 2 of
article 2 talks about the president
being the head of the executive branch
of government and the commander-in-chief
of the Armed Forces who on earth knows
what Donald Trump was talking about when
he mentioned section 2 and then article
2 but at least at some point he seemed
to have the presence of mind to realize
he doesn't actually know what the hell
he's talking about
this is Trump though okay when he was in
private business
he would threaten to sue anyone in
business that he didn't like that was
his strategy and based on what we know
from Michael Cohen his former personal
attorney that was a pretty effective
strategy siccing Michael Cohen the
attack dog on people with threats of
lawsuits was a pretty effective way to
get compliance from the people he wanted
to get compliance from now he's
threatening people with prison because
he's President of the United States it
is truly chilling to see him waive
prison time around to reporters in this
way and I know that there will be from
piss who see this and say David it was a
vague threat he's generally talking
about prison freedom of the press is one
of the most important of speech freedoms
that we have in this country and a
president threatening or even mentioning
prison to a reporter in this way is
unheard of except in extremely
authoritarian dictatorial circles and
that is exactly what Donald Trump
aspires to and that's why this is so
chilling and dangerous let me know what
you think make sure you're following me
on instagram at david pakman make sure
while you're there you follow the show
on instagram at david pakman show
today's sponsor is Skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]